Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
♪ Joy to the world ♪
...bring on the holiday cheer.
Whew. Let's do this.
Is that a Christmas tree
you have tattooed on you?
Bliss: Yeah, that's the drawing
from the patent.
Wow.
That's dedication.
You're all in.
You can literally rock out
for hours at a time.
Cha‐ching!            Cha‐ching!
[ Laughter ]
Why would anybody want this?
Who cares?
Le‐Let's take a step back
for a second.
We've been at this
for less than six months.
Sorry,
you have no sales?
No sales yet,
no sales yet.
[ All groan ]
I've never quit anything
in my life.
My Christmas gift to you
is the truth.
Does he look like
Mr. Christmas?
I'll take a flier.
Don't do it,
Robert.
Just undercut Barbara.
Well, screw Robert.
So I'll of course underbid him,
just to get rid of him
and get even.
Cuban: Ignore him.
It's a dog. It doesn't
matter if we give you
encouragement or not.
He's an idiot!
This is a dog!
[ Howls ]
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a cozy way to stay warm
during the holidays.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Brian Special.
And I'm
Michael Special.
And we are...
The Special Brothers!
[ Laughter ]
We're seeking $50,00 in exchange
for 20% of our company,
and as you're about
to see...
And hear.
...we have a product
that's even more memorable
than our last name.
And it's the holiday season, so
we're going all in on this one.
It's our big moment, bro,
let's go for it.
You s‐‐
You sure about this?
I'm ready.
Oh, boy.
[ Chuckles ]
[ To tune of "Deck The Halls" ]
♪ 'Tis the season of the comfy ♪
♪ Fa‐la‐la‐la‐la,
la‐la‐la‐la ♪
♪ It's the blanket
that's a sweatshirt ♪
♪ Fa‐la‐la‐la‐la,
la‐la‐la‐la ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Stay warm and cozy ♪
♪ It's the Comfy ♪
♪ The perfect gift
for anyone on your list ♪
♪ Get one now before ♪
♪ They're all gone ♪
♪ Fa‐la‐la‐la‐la,
it's Comfy time ♪
Yeah!
Michael:
Nailed it! Whoo!
Cuban:
Nailed it!
Imagine, Sharks, you're just
waking up in the morning
or you're driving home
from work.
It's cold outside.
It's nasty.
All you want is to be warm
and cozy, you know, comfy.
Well, that's exactly what
the Comfy is designed to solve.
Because it's a blanket...
[ Laughter ]
...it's perfect
for lounging around the house
in total luxury.
And because
it's a sweatshirt,
it goes with you and keeps
you warm wherever you are.
Oh, my gosh.
The possibilities
are endless,
and kids ‐‐
they love the Comfy.
Sharks, we probably know
what you're thinking ‐‐
this is
just another version
of one of those
infomercial products.
And, well, maybe.
Hopefully.
It is.
Cha‐ching!
[ Laughter ]
It's made of a soft microfiber
on the outside
and even more luxurious sherpa
on the inside.
Oh.
The pocket is large enough
to fit a phone
or even a tablet,
and the oversized hood
can double as a pillow.
Imagine having that
on an airplane.
And it's very easy to pull in
your arms and your knees
so you can be
completely covered.
But wait!
There's more!      There's more!
What?!
Boy,
is there ever, Sharks!
Not only is the Comfy
one size fits all,
making it perfect
for manufacturing
and also for men,
women, and children
of all shapes
and all sizes,
but the Comfy, Sharks,
is also ‐‐
wait for it...
reversible.
[ Laughs ]
Giving your comfort
some serious style options.
Corcoran:
Looks cute on you.
Yeah, I like that.
Yeah.
So, which one of you
is ready to get comfy with us
so that we can all
make a lot of money,
and, of course,
sing together.
♪ Joy to the world,
the Comfy's here ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
O'Leary: Okay.
Michael: And, Sharks,
we have presents.
[ Chatter ]
I bet we're getting
a Comfy.
Cool.
Here you go,
Mark.
Got it.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
And Lori.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Mr. Wonderful.
Even Kevin
gets a Christmas gift?
There we go.
Wow.
Presents for all.
Thank you, dear.
You're welcome.
Herjavec:
Thank you.
You're welcome.
My head's too big.
[ Laughs ]
We'd love if you guys would
come up and try it on the couch.
Corcoran:
I'll try it.
Where it's ‐‐ Where it's
meant to be worn.
Yes, absolutely.
Kevin looks like
the Grim Reaper.
Uh‐oh.
[ Laughter ]
Ahh...
What a
beautiful picture.
Is that comfy
or what?
It's pretty comfy.
Brian: Yeah!
Yeah! Warm.
Michael:
Oh, yeah. See?
Did anybody...
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Barbara,
what are you doing under there?!
You have no idea!
What a disappointment!
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Kevin,
you look just like ‐‐
You know,
Kevin looks pretty good in that.
Feels very...comfy.
It's the Grim Reaper.
Greiner: It fits you.
It suits you.
It does get kinda warm.
O'Leary: Okay,
I'm really hot now.
Herjavec: So,
have you sold any,
or is this
a brand‐new invention?
Brand‐new.
We've been at this
for less than six months.
You ‐‐ Sorry,
you have no sales?
No sales yet,
no sales yet.
We are ready to put in
our first major order ‐‐
So what is
the distribution plan?
To be completely online ‐‐
at this point.
That is ‐‐
That's what we want to ‐‐
What are you gonna sell it for?
How much?
Uh,
$39.99 is retail.
And what's it cost you
to make?
$13 to make.
$17 landed.
$17.
Mm‐hmm.
Not a great margin,
but...
It comes in one size,
I presume.
One size.
Michael:
One size fits all.
Very easy for manufacture.
Cuban: And how low
can you get the price?
We can get it as low
right now ‐‐ right around $11.
How many units?
About 100,000.
That's a lot of units.
How did you make it?
How'd you come up with it?
Uh, well,
the story goes...
We're both single dads.
From Phoenix, believe it or not.
We invented this in the heat.
And, uh, unfortunately, I'm ‐‐
I'm going through a divorce.
We have
two beautiful kids.
It's the last thing in the world
that I wanted.
And for those first
six months after that,
I was
absolutely devastated.
And so my brother
took me in,
and, uh, my nephew, his son,
which you see right here.
That's Saxon.
He was, uh, sitting
on the couch one morning.
I got up,
and he was wearing
one of my brother's sweatshirts.
Ah.
And he had ‐‐
was up on the couch.
He had his knees
pulled in.
He had ‐‐ He had his arms
I walked by,
and I'm like,
"Whoa, Saxon,
you look so comfortable.
And cozy and warm."
And he's like,
"Yeah, I am."
Looked at my brother
and said,
"You think
we could make these for adults?"
[ Chuckles ]
"Yeah, why not?"
Right?
And then, laying over
the back of the couch
was a blanket, you know,
fleecy sherpa blanket.
We looked at it
and said,
"Well, why don't we make it
out of that material?
And that's
how it was born.
What was the original...
Let's not mention
the other one.
What was its price
at its heyday, at its peak?
I believe
it was $19.95.
Greiner: It was.
The thing is ‐‐
here's the problem for me.
I love you guys.
You are funny, you are nice,
you are wonderful.
But the big elephant in the room
for me is,
the "other one"
that you mentioned?
It's just like it
except it has a hood.
It's not
just like it.
Lori, what was the other one?
What was the other one?
It's called the Snuggie.
It is absolutely
not the Snuggie.
No, but the thing is,
the Snuggie's still being sold,
and ‐‐ and I actually
do a lot of business
with the people
that created it.
Oh, the Snuggie.
I like products
that are unique.
This is not unique enough.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you for the feedback.
Do you guys know how much money
the Snuggie made?
It sold 22 million units
its first year.
22 million units?
What?
Michael:
Units in its first year.
It's a product
for everyone.
Corcoran: But could you please
explain to me
what the difference between
your product is and the Snuggie?
Okay, so if you were
on the couch with the Snuggie
and you wanted to get up
to go do something,
you have to take it off
every time.
And you're ‐‐
it's open in the back.
It's like having
a robe on backwards.
We're not knocking
the Snuggie,
but this is
a significant improvement.
Cuban: But that ‐‐ that's
not the issue for me,
right? I think it's great.
I think it's comfy.
I'd like to have one.
But the problem is, even if
you get your cost down, right,
you're gonna be burning through
a lot of cash
in order to figure out what
works and what doesn't work.
And so while
I think it's great,
I think you have a lot of
work to do before you're ready.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
All right. Thank you
for the feedback, Mark.
Thanks for the feedback.
Appreciate that.
So, what is it, you don't have
the cash to go to production?
We do.
No, we're ready.
You do.
We do.
But what you have right now
is still a sample.
Do you have the money
for the inventory?
Yes.
We do.
So what do you need
the $50,000 for today?
For more inventory.
Yeah.
But you haven't sold
the first inventory.
No, we haven't,
but...
Cuban:
They're confident.
We're very confident.
We are ‐‐ We are confident.
I mean, we are on ‐‐
What's missing from the pitch is
the customer acquisition cost.
Selling it at $39.99,
it costs me $17 landed, right?
I have that margin
to play with.
But how do I know
that's not all gonna be eaten up
by customer acquisition costs?
And until I know what that is,
I mean, it's...
I think
we have a product
that is, uh,
a potential viral product.
I mean, we're obviously
gonna take it online.
Everybody says that.
No one's ever come here,
stood there, and said...
"We suck."
..."We suck and we don't have
any chance of being viral."
Corcoran: Tell me a little bit
about your website,
or don't you have one?
We ‐‐ No, we do not
have it yet
because we're about
two months away from launching.
We're ‐‐
We don't even have
a final product yet
to take pictures of
and everything else.
[ Laughs ]
We're ‐‐ We're getting that
early next week.
You have the worst answers
to the questions...
Yeah.
...but it comes across
so nice.
Okay.
Hey, we're living
the entrepreneurial dream.
We're on sacred ground
right here.
Amen!
All right. Robert?
Herjavec: Yeah.
This is your big chance.
Michael: Come on, Robert!
That a flier with us.
Love you guys!
You seem so genuine.
You're not gonna have to do
any of the work.
We will do it.
We'll do the work.
I‐I got to be honest with you,
I have never seen a Snuggie.
But $22 million in sales,
units?
I'm all over that.
Sometimes, it's okay
to be number two or three
in a really big market.
Don't do it, Robert.
I'll take a flier.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out,
but Robert seems interested
in Michael and Brian's
sweatshirt blanket,
The Original Comfy.
I'll take a flier.
I'll do the $50,000 for 50%.
[ All groan ]
O'Leary: Ooh!
You know what,
that offer makes me comfy.
[ Laughter ]
That's not a flier ‐‐
that's a fat tire.
Getting a little hot
in here.
It's like your thing...
and it's the only offer.
Ouch.
It's the only offer.
Thank you for the offer.
We really do appreciate that.
Oh, my goodness.
I'd love to hear if Barbara
has something to say.
That's pretty greedy,
Robert.
You know what I really
don't like about Robert?
He said,
"Let's do this deal together.
Let's do this...,"
and I'm like "Okay,"
and then
he makes the offer without me.
Well, screw Robert.
I was just starting,
Barbara.
Yeah, you weren't starting ‐‐
you started and you finished.
Okay.
So I'll of course
underbid him,
even though I don't
want to, just to get rid
of him and get even.
Okay.
$50,000 for 30%.
But you do
all the work.
I'm gonna know
how to market it.
I think you hyper‐focus online,
and I can help you there
because I've sold
so much product online.
♪♪
Barbara, would you consider
$50,000 for 25%?
And you have a deal.
You know, I'd say not.
Herjavec: Ohh.
O'Leary: Wow.
Oh.
Guys,
you haven't heard from me yet.
We haven't.
And we would love to.
There's always
the possibility ‐‐
I thought
you were out!
No,
I'm not out.
No.
I have not spoken yet, Robert,
and I need silence.
♪♪
I'm out.
[ Laughter ]
Well, thank you
for that incredible feedback,
Mr. Wonderful.
Was amazing.
But you have
two viable offers.
Okay.
What you say?
Yeah?
Want to do it?
♪♪
Yeah?
Mm‐hmm.
Let's go.
Barbara...
♪♪
You have a deal.
Okie dokie.
[ Applause ]
Let's get comfy together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys
are phenomenal salespeople.
Thank you.
Terrific.
Great salespeople.
This is
gonna be great.
Terrific.
Thank you.
Good luck to you.
Cuban:
Congrats, guys.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for
the feedback.
We appreciate it
very much.
Good luck, guys.
Whoo!
You know, Kevin...
[ Greiner laughs ]
that was
The Art of the Pitch.
Really?
Yes.
Yeah, they were
great salespeople.
I didn't notice that.
Yes.
What you're saying, Robert,
is you can walk in here
with poo poo on a stick,
sing a song,
and get $50,000 from Barbara.
[ Laughter ]
We nailed it.
It happened.
We got it.
If you get up ‐‐
And...
If you get up
and get off the couch...
Yeah.
...and do something
when you have an idea...
Yep.
...you could
be here, too.
Absolutely.
It's the American Dream.
"Shark Tank."
And we did it.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 6,
Andrea Sreshta and Anna Stork
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for LuminAID,
solar‐powered lights
for emergencies.
Let's see
what they're doing now.
Stork: We're in
Puerto Rico today
with one of our
charitable partners,
Convoy of Hope,
to distribute lights to those
affected by Hurricane Maria.
Sreshta:
2017 has had
an especially devastating
hurricane season,
between hurricanes Harvey,
Irma, and Maria.
Hurricane Maria hit Puerto Rico
as a Category 4 hurricane
with over
155 mile‐per‐hour winds.
It's been 4 weeks,
and 90% of people
are still living without power.
We are giving out our newest
product to those in need.
It's a solar inflatable lantern
that doubles as a battery
so you can also charge your
phone and connect to loved ones.
As soon
as Hurricane Harvey hit,
Mark reached out
and immediately got involved
in what we were doing
to help victims
and first responders.
Mark even sent down
his Mavericks team plane
loaded with food, water,
and supplies to Puerto Rico.
Since "Shark Tank,"
we've now sold
over half a million
LuminAID lights,
and we've done
over $7 1/2 million in sales.
And we've provided over 125,000
lights for humanitarian aid
to people
in more than 100 countries.
Wow,
look at all the debris.
This hurricane season has been
incredibly personal for us.
My parents' house
and garage flooded in Houston,
and that garage actually served
at LuminAID's first warehouse.
And so it kind of
comes full circle.
Press it on,
like that.
I think
in times like this,
when people are waiting
for the power to come back on,
giving them a form
of portable power
gives them
a little bit of hope
that really,
they need right now.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Gracias.
And we're just glad that
our lights and our phone
chargers are there to help.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
what the entrepreneur believes
is a solution
to an unsightly holiday problem.
♪♪
Happy holidays, Sharks!
My name's Ryan Kenny,
and this Christmas,
I'm asking for $100,000
in exchange for
20% equity of my company,
The Christmas Tree Hugger.
This little guy right here
is The Christmas Tree Hugger,
and we're here to fix the fake.
Now, what do I mean by that?
Well, every year, millions
of artificial‐tree owners
put their trees up
and decorate them,
making them look
as perfect as possible.
But almost every artificial tree
has the same ugly secret
down below.
This fuzzy‐looking green eyesore
looks nothing like a real tree.
It takes away from
all that holiday magic.
But with
The Christmas Tree Hugger,
you can go from faking it...
to making it, like that.
And you can even use it
to hide your messy cords.
Just run them
through the Hugger,
under the skirt,
and they're gone.
It's as easy as putting on
an ornament.
We have our classic brown bark.
We have birch bark, too.
All of
our Christmas Tree Huggers
reverse to candy cane...
[ Chuckles ]
...so in seconds,
you can go from classy to crazy
and make your tree more fun,
festive,
and a happy thing
to look at during the holiday.
So in the spirit
of the holiday season,
let's just hug it out and
give artificial Christmas trees
the Christmas miracles
they deserve.
And I'd like to hand out
some samples.
Please.
Yep.
Corcoran: Aww,
a little stocking. How cute.
Thank you,
sir.
Yeah,
you're welcome.
Appreciate it.
Aww, you put
our names on it.
Thank you.
Does it say "Grinch,"
Kevin?
[ Chuckles ]
Herjavec:
Thank you, Ryan.
So, Ryan,
do you also have a real job?
Kenny:
Yes, I have a real job.
I'm in advertising.
I'm an art director,
so I'm a pretty creative guy.
How did you come up
with the idea?
Well, my wife and I bought
our first artificial tree,
and everything
looked pretty good,
but then we kind of noticed that
fuzzy green pole at the bottom.
And we were just
scratching our heads ‐‐
"You know, how come no one's
ever made that look better?
It looks nothing like a tree."
So I made a prototype
for my house,
and my wife loved it
and her friends loved it.
And they asked me to put
some online, and it started
selling a little bit.
And then I just started
having fun with it,
and I was like, "You know what?
I think I'm on to something."
Why would
anybody want this?
Who cares?
Well, people do care,
actually.
Really? Who?
Yes!
Well, if you have great sales,
then you prove him wrong.
Yeah.
So, we've been doing this
for a year and a half,
and so far,
our sales are $50,000.
Wow.
What does it cost you
to make one?
It costs us $1.37 to make it.
Oh that's ‐‐ With packaging
and everything...
With packaging, yeah.
We sell it for $17.95.
Mostly online?
Uh, we're online.
We're actually with QVC,
as well.
How many
did you sell on QVC?
Uh, we went on
for the Christmas July sale,
and at 1:00 in the morning
managed to sell 1,000 of them
in 5 minutes.
Good for you.
That's not ‐‐ That's not
a good slot, either.
But they're never gonna
invite you back.
Did they invite you back?
All due respect to
your product and everything...
Yes, we're ‐‐ we're talking
about going back
closer to the holidays.
How many
did they reorder?
Well, we still have the ones
that are in stock,
so they have ‐‐
they're gonna sell through...
How many
did they bring in?
They brought in 5,000 units.
Did they reorder,
or they're just gonna
air them again?
Well, I think
we're gonna air them again,
but right now, it's QVC customer
top‐rated, too,
and it's been getting
five‐star reviews.
And was the price
on QVC $17.95, as well,
or was it lower?
They're selling it
for $20.
Oh,
that's even better!
So you made
$20,000 on QVC
in 5 minutes
at 1:00 in the morning.
Yeah, that was all
new to me.
That was my first time
ever doing anything like that.
It was ‐‐ It was really fun.
What else
have you sold,
and what are the plans
for this year?
Last year, we did $12,000.
And was that online?
So, I made a cold call...
To?
...right away, to Kroger...
Uh‐huh.
...and my first call
with the lady,
she loved it and she wanted
to put it in the store,
so we put it in Kroger.
And how much
was that order for?
That order was for 130 stores,
and they ordered 1,500 units.
Right out of the gate.
They never reordered?
They sold 40% of the units.
Are they gonna
reorder it again?
They're not
gonna reorder it again.
Why's that
a good story?
[ Laughs ]
Well,
it's a good story
'cause we're learning
from our mistakes, and ‐‐
Why aren't they
gonna reorder, Ryan?
'Cause it doesn't sell!
It didn't sell through
well enough.
Kenny: It didn't sell through
It's a grocery store.
It's probably not the perfect
place for a product like this.
But it wasn't wrong for you
to take the order.
But we're gonna
take the deal,
'cause it's an opportunity,
right?
Right.
What will revenues be
this year?
If we sell through
the stuff that we have,
we're looking at $220,000
in sales.
And how much do you think
you'll make on that?
I think we'll probably make
around $110,000.
♪♪
I personally don't see this
as a really big problem.
I like
to invest in things
that fit to
a broad mass audience.
It's just not
the right investment for me,
so I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Thank you for your time.
Herjavec: Ryan,
starting a business
is one of the hardest things
you can do.
I admire you
for that.
But inevitably,
for me to invest,
I have to believe
in the product.
I‐I just don't like
the product.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I have to compliment you
on one thing
that we don't hear
very often.
You made
a sales call yourself,
walked into Kroger.
You got yourself
a big order.
Good for you.
It only sold through 40% ‐‐
just keep making
those cold calls.
10 more orders at 40%
adds up to a lot of money.
My QVC order
was from a cold call.
Well, let me ‐‐
I'm just kind of
going out there
and just not taking no
for an answer.
Well, let me tell you,
you surprised me.
What a great example
to set.
That's awesome.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, let me say it gently ‐‐
I'm out.
Thank you
for your time.
I don't think Barbara's
done you any favor at all
giving you encouragement
to go on.
The market has spoken ‐‐
It doesn't care
about this product.
The reason
you're going back on QVC
is 'cause they want to get rid
of their inventory.
The reason Kroger
didn't reorder it ‐‐
nobody bought it.
The market said no...
That's so not true.
...and so I don't want to
offer you any encouragement.
I want to tell you
to take this behind the barn
and shoot it...
That's ‐‐
...so that it leaves time
for to do something else.
Ignore him.
This product is a dog.
What do you
have to say to that?
You're the first people
who have ever said that.
Every person I've showed
this to, every person I've
cold ‐‐ I've cold called ‐‐
They're lying to you.
Ryan, Ryan.
They are definitely interested.
Here's the reality ‐‐
You picked up the phone,
you called QVC,
you sold $20,000 worth.
You picked up
the phone...
And he made
hundreds of dollars.
...you walked into Kroger's,
and you sold your product.
That's why you're in the
right spot and he's an idiot.
Rah, rah, rah.
Thank you so much.
Herjavec: Mark,
I hate to agree with Kevin,
but at a certain point,
you got to pivot.
Look, what was your sales price
to Kroger?
$6.
$6 ‐‐ So, you made
$4.77 each, right?
Yeah.
And you sold
how many there?
Over 1,000.
So you made almost $5,000,
right, by walking in the door?
Mark, why are you
encouraging him?
You haven't spent
that much time
in closing a deal
in your entire life.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Kevin,
somebody spends some time,
develops a product,
takes the initiative,
sells them ‐‐
in this case, $20,000 worth ‐‐
If you sold it
for more ‐‐
Mark, why can't you say
just once this is a dog?!
It doesn't matter if we give you
encouragement or not...
You're making
good money!
...it's still a dog!
He's an idiot!
Two deals that are ‐‐
that are not ‐‐
[ Howls ]
...yet, for next year,
but they're ‐‐ they're large.
I am out,
but I'm the only Shark
willing to tell you the truth.
One more time ‐‐ Dog.
[ Howls ]
I‐It's really a nice product.
The solution ‐‐
Yeah.
The art director in you
has come out, right,
and it's
a well‐designed package.
I like the concept ‐‐
I just see it as a product,
not a company, and so
for those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you.
My Christmas gift to you
is the truth.
Ryan,
you know what ‐‐
Kevin, I've never quit anything
in my life.
I'm not a quitter.
Good for you.
And this is not something
I'm willing to quit.
Go crush it, Ryan.
Keep on making money.
I'm gonna keep doing this.
Good luck, Ryan.
Congrats, buddy.
♪♪
Like I said,
I do not give up.
I'm in advertising.
We hear stuff like that
all the time.
You got to have thick skin.
That's part of the secret.
You got to love his hustle,
but seriously?
Robert ‐‐
I mean, sell ‐‐
sell something else.
Robert, anybody who could take
a piece of fabric,
put two strips
of Velcro on it,
walk into a store,
and make $5,000 ‐‐
Agree!
You're promoted.
Do it again...
What,
and make another $5,000?
...and do it again,
and ‐‐ Yes!
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a modern innovation
for a retro product.
♪♪
Whoo! Let's do this.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Logan Riley.
I'm from beautiful
San Francisco, California,
and the founder of an
idea company called Pink Donut.
Today, I'm seeking $300,000
in exchange for 15%
of my product, RokBlok.
♪♪
Sharks, anybody recognize
one of these?
Can you believe
that we've been using records
to listen to music
for over 120 years?
You know, in that amount time,
a lot of music formats
have come and gone ‐‐
8‐tracks, cassettes, CDs,
and now digital.
Yet somehow,
these analog beauties
have stood the test of time.
Maybe that's because
with their liner notes,
amazing sound, and of course...
[ Sniffs, sighs ]
Smell. Yeah.
Riley:
...that old vinyl smell.
[ Chuckles ]
Records have always been another
way to just listen to music.
They're an experience.
However,
this experience does come with
its own share of inconvenience
and expense.
For example,
to listen to any record,
you have to have a turntable,
a pair of speakers,
and a good pre‐amp ‐‐ altogether
costs hundreds of dollars.
And in addition, this experience
can only take place
where all of this equipment is.
You can't really
take it anywhere else.
Well, now you can...
with this.
This is RokBlok,
the world's first
infinitely portable,
wireless record player.
Really?
Greiner: Wow.
Wow.
You can literally
take this guy anywhere.
Let me show you how it works.
Using RokBlok is really
just as simple of turning it on,
placing it on top of any record,
and pulling the lever up
to begin playing.
[ Whirring ]
Herjavec:
Oh, wow.
[ Laughs ]
[ Hip‐hop music plays ]
Get out.
Corcoran: Wow.
That is so cool.
To stop playing,
hold your hand above RokBlok
just like this.
[ Music stops ]
Now, if you're like me, you like
your music a little bit louder,
so in addition
to its built‐in speaker,
RokBlok also has the ability
to send its music
to any wireless speakers
or headphones...
like that guy over there
using Bluetooth.
[ Whirring ]
[ Hip‐hop music plays ]
Wow!
Oh! So cool.
Amazing.
[ Music stops ]
With its tiny size, you can
literally take RokBlok anywhere,
while out on the go
with friends or your next dig.
And with its built‐in
rechargeable speaker,
you can literally rock out
for hours at a time
on one single charge.
Whoo!
Can you just play it
on any surface?
Any surface ‐‐ I will always
recommend something go under it,
so here I have a slip mat.
Right.
But any surface ‐‐
I actually have a couple samples
I can hand you guys.
Sure.
Yeah.
Can we see 'em?
Sure.
Any type of vinyl,
like,
you know, it doesn't matter
the size?
Any type of vinyl ‐‐
This plays 33s ‐‐
33s and 45s ‐‐
It doesn't play 78s.
No 78s?!
A little too fast.
There goes
my collection.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
Mm‐hmm.
Corcoran: Pretty remarkable.
Good for you.
Thank you so much.
Really.
Herjavec:
Great invention, Logan.
Looks like a beehive.
I do appreciate that.
Thank you so much.
Oh, I love the case, too.
It's wood.
So, do we have a traditional
phono cartridge in here?
Yes, we do.
And so, because I'm
a bit of a collector,
I've got a lot of albums,
and I care about the quality,
what's the actual quality
on a Bluetooth
I put through
the stereo system?
What does
it sound like?
It sounds great.
Now, the thing is, Bluetooth
is compressing the sound.
Yeah.
So, with that in mind,
there is going some be loss ‐‐
somewhat of a loss in quality,
but to be honest,
most people can't discern
the d‐‐
uh, the difference in quality
between analog or Bluetooth.
That's half the ‐‐
But, Logan, if you're into vinyl
and you cherish your records,
why would you
be taking them anywhere
to play just
in some random place?
In my case, I see not just
a place to take it with you,
I also see it as a way
for people
who don't have room
for all this equipment.
So, for example, I live in
a tiny, 300‐square‐foot studio.
But yeah, how many of those
people are gonna be audiophiles?
Now you're taking ‐‐
you're shrinking
your potential population
for sales down considerably.
I actually think it's growing,
and the reason why I say that
is not just for audiophiles.
I see this as an entry
into getting into records
in the first place,
so I see ‐‐
Herjavec: So,
you're thinking people
that can't afford
a record player.
Absolutely.
I would have never
gotten into records before.
I just don't know
that there's that many.
What do you sell
one unit for?
They retail at $99.
Oh.
And it costs me $23 to make.
And what are
your sales so far?
So far ‐‐ I started
a Kickstarter in 2016
with $350,000 in total sales.
And besides Kickstarter,
what are your sales?
I have presold an additional
$60,000 worth of RokBloks.
So, you haven't ‐‐
Have you delivered anything yet?
I'm actually in production
as we speak.
But we don't know what the
mass audience is going to think
of the product yet.
We don't have the
feedback 'cause you
haven't delivered yet.
That's true,
but I've spent so much time
making sure
this is a great product,
as an audiophile myself
and somebody who really believes
in making great products ‐‐
Yeah, but people fall in love
with their own products,
particularly inventors.
It has nothing to do with
how the audience receives it
once they have it
in their hands.
Absolutely.
How much money have you raised
for this?
Zero. I put $2,000 of my own
money to build my prototype.
That's it?
Good for you.
With the money from Kickstarter,
I spent that
on the pre‐production costs,
which includes the tooling.
And to save money,
I actually lived in China,
slept at my manufacturer's
office for two months.
Wow.
How'd you come up
with this?
So, I started off ‐‐
I'm a ‐‐ I'm a vinyl‐head.
I go record shopping
every Saturday.
And one Saturday, my friends
were at a park and said,
"Hey, come meet up with us."
So, I have my vinyl with me.
Everybody's interested
in my vinyls.
And it was like, "Wow.
What'd you get?
What'd you get?"
And everybody's going through
my vinyls.
They're like,
"Let's listen to some."
And I'm like,
"Well, there's really no way
I can let you listen to these."
I mean,
my apartment is about the size
of Mr. Wonderful's tie closet.
[ Laughs ]
I can't fit anybody in
my apartment at 300 square feet.
And so I wanted to find a way
that I could share my records
with my friends or families.
So, I wanted something
that I could take with me,
but usually,
portable record players are big,
'cause they have to be
the size of a record
in order for the record to spin.
So, then, I thought about it ‐‐
rather than the record spinning,
what if I made a unit
that spun around the record?
Then,
it could be any size I want,
and I could take it with me.
So, that's when I first started
on the prototype
that became RokBlok.
What's your background?
How did you know
how to make something like this?
Yeah. You know, actually, this
was my first hardware project.
I taught myself electrical
engineering on YouTube.
So, you're not
an engineer?
So, you didn't hire
an engineer ‐‐
you figured this all out
by yourself?
That's impressive.
Did you file a patent
on this?
I did file a utility patent.
A utility patent.
And that covers the wireless
transmission of audio from
a stationary disc.
You never told us
the rest of your background.
Do you mind
just finishing that?
Yeah, so, my background ‐‐
I do have a background
in audio engineering.
I used to run a recording studio
when I was 19.
Spent five years
working at Apple
with education technologies,
so building ‐‐
teaching, building tools
to teach consumers
how to use the products.
I also did that at
Pandora Internet Radio, as well.
So, I'm investing in you
as an inventor
and everything you invent,
or is it just for RokBlok?
This would just be for RokBlok.
Whoa,
hold on there, Baba Looey.
[ Laughter ]
Baba Looey?
Why would I do that?
[ Chuckling ]
Baba Looey.
Why would I do that?
RokBlok is ‐‐ is ‐‐
is a really ‐‐
So you're just letting me invest
in one single product?
I think each one of my ideas
can be something
completely separate,
and the fun thing is,
if we make a partnership today,
I have more ideas
that I can bring to you.
Corcoran: Yeah. Logan,
I'm gonna simplify things
a little bit here.
It's clever ‐‐
my hat off to you ‐‐
but I think
it's way too early.
Even your Kickstarter supporters
haven't tested it out,
never mind
the open market.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
I appreciate your time.
Thank you so much.
I don't know that there's
a big enough market for this,
and I think
you'll get bored
if it doesn't sell
right off the bat
and go on
to your next thing.
I‐I think
that's a problem.
Two, I hate working
with perpetual inventors ‐‐
hate it, right?
Because every one's
your baby
until
the next kid's born.
You know?
It's 'cause you go ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Well‐said.
And it's just ‐‐
it just drives me crazy.
It's not about
running the company.
So, for those reasons, I wish
you the best, but I'm out.
I appreciate your time.
Thank you, Mark.
O'Leary: I'm looking at it
with the risk being
that we don't have thousands
of them out on the market,
so we don't know
what consumers are gonna say
and how the product
will stand up ‐‐ all of that.
Having said all that, too,
I‐I like it.
I think there's a niche market
in vinyl.
I don't think it's worth
2 million bucks 'cause
it's kind of unproven.
I'll do this deal ‐‐
I'll give you the 300K for 50%.
I want to be ‐‐
5‐0?
5‐0, yeah.
Half.
And you're
a very impressive guy, okay?
But the risk
is huge,
and it's not
a small amount of money.
I really appreciate that offer.
Thank you so much.
With respect
to this once‐in‐a‐lifetime
opportunity ‐‐
Well, you should,
'cause it's the only one
you have right now.
Absolutely.
With respect, I would like
to just check and see.
I understand what happens
when I ‐‐ when I check and see
if anybody else has an offer,
but with respect ‐‐
Well, let's see if anybody else
has an offer.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Kevin's made an offer
of $300,000 for a 50% stake
of Logan's
portable vinyl player, RokBlok,
but Logan wants to see
if there are any other offers.
With respect, I would like
to just check and see.
I understand what happens
when I ‐‐ when I check and see
if anybody else has an offer,
but with respect ‐‐
Well, let's see if anybody else
has an offer.
[ Chuckles ]
Greiner: I think
this is clever.
I know that the millennials
are into vinyl
and it's, like,
a cool thing again,
but it's expensive
for something
where you have
this niche market,
so, you know,
I‐I'm really ‐‐
I'm really on the fence
about this.
Look, I'm not on the fence.
I love it.
I think
it's a beautiful design.
I think it's gonna be
a slow burn.
I don't think it's gonna be
one of these products
that goes to millions
right away,
but I think it'll sell
for a very long time.
I think
you're a great design guy,
but I think you're gonna want
to go do the next thing.
Here's my offer,
and it's a little bit different.
♪♪
Sell it to me.
I'll pay you $500,000
for 100% of RokBlok.
I'll hire you
for two years
at a
six‐figure contract.
We'll figure that out.
That way, you have a job
for a couple of years
to help us get it out
in the market,
and then
we'll pay you a royalty
for every one we sell
going forward.
I'm thinking
something like $5 a unit.
That's my offer.
If you don't say yes
right now ‐‐
Wow.
I'm gonna say yes to that
right now.
Corcoran: Of course.
Done.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
Wow.
Thank you so much.
This is amazing.
I love it.
Thank you so much.
It's beautiful.
Oh, my Lord.
You just turned yourself
into an employee.
[ Laughter ]
That's okay, Logan ‐‐
a rich employee.
Half a million dollars, Logan.
That's great.
As long as I can continue
focusing on RokBlok
and build other things,
I'm gonna be
a very happy person.
Congratulations, Logan.
Thank you so much.
♪♪
[ Sighs deeply ] Wow.
Robert understood me.
He understands that I want to
continue creating more products,
and he knew that this deal
was going to be a way for me
to still have skin in the game
with RokBlok,
but still create more things.
I couldn't have asked
for anything more.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the tank
is a modern version
of a holiday tradition.
♪♪
Happy holidays, Sharks.
My name is Matt Bliss.
My company,
Modern Christmas Trees,
is based in Denver, Colorado,
and I'm here today
seeking $100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company.
Modern Christmas Trees
is illuminating the holidays
in a new and memorable way.
Like the sound of a grand piano
can fill any‐size room,
so does the light and the magic
associated with
each of these trees.
Look how they seem to just float
in the air.
These trees come
in several different colors,
sizes, and styles,
each of which elicits
a different feeling and emotion.
We have the full tree
that you see here in green,
we have the half tree that fits
flush against the wall,
and up front, we have
the new Table Top Jubilee.
Modern Christmas Trees
is both art and ease.
They're made of concentric,
collapsible rings...
Cuban:
Oh, wow.
Corcoran:
Pretty cool.
...making them easy
to put up...
Wow.
...easy to take down,
and they even store flat
in their own zipper case.
These trees have been
a tradition in my family
for over 50 years,
and with your guys' help,
we can spread
the joy they create
to families all over the world.
You said this has been
a family tradition for 50 years?
So, the tree was inspired
by my grandfather,
who designed a tree
originally made out of cardboard
that was made
of concentric rings.
Herjavec: Wow.
Is that him?
Bliss:
That's him.
That's great.
O'Leary:
Is he still with us?
No, he passed away.
Um, part of my motivation
behind this
is he was diagnosed
with Alzheimer's
in, uh...
[Voice breaking] in 2010.
And that was a tough thing
for our family.
And, um...
I felt very helpless,
and I wanted to do something
for him.
And I figured
the best thing that I could do
would be to create a legacy
for him.
Herjavec: Did he sell it
at all or...
No, he did not.
Is that a Christmas tree
you have tattooed on your arm?
Yeah, that is the ‐‐ that's
the drawing from the patent.
Wow!
That's dedication.
And then, this is the photo
of my grandfather.
You're all‐in.
Greiner: Oh!
You're all‐in,
Matt.
Corcoran: Wow.
Matt, do they always
have to hang from the ceiling?
I noticed that one's
hanging from ‐‐
They do not. So, this one
hangs from the ceiling,
and it weighs a total
of about 14 pounds.
So, there's just a little
plastic drywall screw.
But the other one
hangs on the side of the wall.
That's correct.
Tell me what you're gonna sell
this year.
So, this year, we're on track
to do $380,800.
So, I ‐‐
That's pretty specific.
How ‐‐ Why ‐‐ How did you get
to that number?
Well, we've had growth
of 70% per year.
How many years?
Since ‐‐ 2014
is when I quit my job.
Okay.
So, I spent 2012 and '13
learning the marketplace,
learning about
who the customer might be.
So, what was the first step
you took to sell it?
Um, there is a trade show called
the Denver Modernism Show.
I made two trees,
and I put the trees up,
and I kind of ran away
and just kind of listened
to what people said.
[ Laughs ]
I wanted an honest opinion
about it.
Smart.
Yeah,
and, so, um, people loved them.
What does it cost
for the big one?
So, the big one,
fully decorated ‐‐
uh, it costs me $232.
Wow.
What do
you sell it for?
$799 it retails for.
Oh.
Wow, that's pricey.
Hello! Yeah.
O'Leary:
Ouch. Ouch.
Herjavec: Wow.
That's a lot.
Greiner:
It's your crystals.
It comes with
96 crystal ornaments...
So, the big que‐‐
the question becomes ‐‐
...96 glass‐ball ornaments,
the LED light,
a zipper case
that the tree collapses into.
I see a material challenge here
in rolling this out.
Most families don't have $799
to spend.
And this obviously is not
designed for most families.
That's correct.
But, you know,
we've had many...
It's cool,
though.
...products like this
in "Shark Tank."
I have one
called "GeekMyTree."
Yep.
And what we learned was,
you can't sell
Christmas ornaments
for large
amounts of money
'cause people only use them
for a few weeks.
Right.
You want to have
a low price point.
I think the challenge
for this product
is it has to be displayed
for people to understand
its potential as a product.
Where are your sales
coming from?
It ‐‐ It ‐‐ It's about 80%
through the website
and 20% through retail.
And so,
you've got a ton of margin.
So, we sent it through companies
like Frontgate...
Corcoran: Ah,
that's a good one.
...Brookstone,
Hammacher Schlemmer.
Yeah.
Well, you should be making
some money.
How much money are you gonna
make off your $388,000?
Uh, about half that.
Half?
Good for you.
O'Leary:
Wow.
O'Leary: It's a good thing
for you.
You know, I look at this
as a very niche product.
It's beautiful.
It's really expensive.
Let ‐‐ Let ‐‐ Let's take a step
back for a second, if we could.
If we were to sell them
at a lower price point,
we could reach
a much larger market.
No, I'm not suggest‐‐
I'm not suggesting
you should change your pricing.
This is a very niche,
expensive, premium, high‐end ‐‐
whatever you want
to define it as.
Mm‐hmm.
I mean, I'm ‐‐ I'm steeped in
that market through GeekMyTree.
You're in part of the market
that's probably 3%.
No, you're wrong.
Really?
How come
you have no sales?
Tell him, Matt!
You're $800
before shipping.
The ‐‐ The billion‐dollar
marketplace,
which is the artificial
Christmas tree market ‐‐
20% of the customers
that make up that market
are $200 artificial
Christmas trees and higher.
Corcoran: Mm.
Matt, look, first of all ‐‐
beautiful product.
The challenge I have is
I don't see it scaling
to be a $10 million,
$20 million,
$50 million business.
For me, that's where
I have to see it going.
I'm out.
Herjavec:
Look, uh...
beautiful design.
♪♪
I almost see it in the lobby
of a hotel, much larger.
Yes.
I will definitely
be a customer,
but at $800, I think it's
a relatively limited market.
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
♪♪
I appreciate it.
Matt, it's too expensive,
period.
♪♪
I'm out.
Corcoran:
What do you think, Lori?
You've got a good nose
for all this stuff.
Well,
I think it's beautiful.
I'm obviously into crystals
and sparkly things.
To me, what makes it beautiful
is a lot of the crystals
and the light show
that's going on in the ceiling.
Mm‐hmm. Right.
It's unique.
It's different.
What I don't love
is the price point.
It's gorgeous,
but on this one,
my gut is telling me
I have to go out.
♪♪
Cuban: So, you have
one Shark left, Matt.
Herjavec: Barbara.
There's a lot
I don't like about it.
I don't like the fact
that you have to display it.
I think the $800 price
is an enormous price.
I think
you have a lot of SKUs,
which are
a pain in the neck.
It means
more production cost.
But the minute you started
talking from your heart
about your grandfather and
your love of what you're doing,
you came to life.
I'm gonna offer you $100,000
for 25%,
but on top of that, I really
want the $100,000 paid back ‐‐
5 bucks a tree.
I don't care what the size is.
Do you know, when I looked at
that Frontgate catalog recently,
they must have had 20 trees
in the $800‐to‐$1,300 mark.
Yes.
And this is so fresh
and different.
Right.
So fresh and different ‐‐
that's your luxury market.
So, that's my deal,
all right?
Are you willing
to pay a royalty?
Just till
I'm paid back.
Makes sense.
For 25%?
For 25%.
Cuban: It's a great offer,
Matt.
I'll do it for 20%.
♪♪
Same deal for 20%.
Does he look like
Mr. Christmas?
And I want the royalty.
And I'm in
the Christmas business.
Herjavec: Wow.
So, now you got two.
I'm in the space.
Just undercut Barbara.
You got Grinch...
Corcoran:
That's not very nice.
...and you got Barbara.
I'll drop down
to 20%.
Ooh!
'Cause I want to see
how far he'll drop his pants.
I think Barbara
was being exceptionally greedy
at a time of year
where you should be generous,
for Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec:
So...it's simple ‐‐
do you want Barbara
at your Christmas dinner,
or do you want Kevin?
[ Laughter ]
And ‐‐ And, remember,
there's only one Mr. Wonderful.
And we're thankful
for that.
I'm in the Christmas business,
and I was thinking,
"What could we do
with the lighting?"
GeekMyTree has
some remarkable displays ‐‐
You don't have to do a thing
with the lighting.
You've got
a perfect product here.
Herjavec: Yeah, it's perfect.
You just
have to get it out there.
So, you're at 25%.
No, she's at 20%.
She's at 20%.
No, I dropped to 20%,
yeah.
Okay. Okay.
20% for you ‐‐ that was
my Christmas gift to you.
[ Laughs ]
Now we're both
at the same place.
Oh, no, we're not,
because I'm coming down to 19%,
but you have to say yes or no
right now.
19%.
To 19%, Matt.
Yes or no ‐‐
what do you say?
♪♪
Uh.
It's ‐‐ It's just more equity
than I‐I'd like to do.
Um...
What doors do you think
that you could help me open?
Oh, now he's making you sell,
Barbara. I d‐‐
Can I tell you ‐‐
No, I don't mind selling at all.
You just give me a list
of what doors you want open,
and they
will be open.
O'Leary: Matt, here we are
at Christmas.
I don't feel the love.
And remember,
I got you that 5%.
Barbara would have stayed at 25%
had I not come back in.
But you have to
make a decision.
What do you
want to do, Matt?
♪♪
Barbara,
do we have a deal at 15%?
Ohh!
Ooh!
Corcoran: Um...
18%, it's a deal.
♪♪
Let's do this.
Yeah, baby!
Yeah!
[ Light laughter ]
Come to Mama,
baby.
Come to Mama.
[ Laughter ]
You really don't need
much of my help,
but I'll help you out ‐‐
whatever you need.
Thanks ‐‐ Thanks for ‐‐
Thanks for believing in me.
Oh, wholeheartedly.
That's great.
With the tattoo, how could I not
believe in you ‐‐
your grandpa
on your arm?
Cuban: Matt, I want you to know
she meant it.
O'Leary:
Under the tree this year,
when you open the present
from Mr. Wonderful...
Nice.
...there'll be a lump of coal
in there.
Bliss: Ah.
Congrats, Matt.
Thanks a lot.
Greiner:
Congrats, Matt.
Thank you.
Cuban: Great job.
This is a great day
for my Grandpa Bud.
I know he's up there,
smiling down.
I'm glad I was able
to represent our family
and represent his ingenuity
and be able
to share that with the world.
♪♪